what's going on guys my name is J and in
this video I'm gonna show you how I use
gulp almost everyday if you don't know
what gulp is I want to show you very
quickly what one of the things that you
can do with it so right now I have here
a very basic website you can see that
I'm requesting a style dot CSS file now
I don't have this file yet because I'm
using sass as you can see here so this
all some sass code so I need to compile
this code 2 or C so a CSS file only one
CSS file but then after that I want to
minify that CSS file and then use the
CSS file
it sounds very complicated but that's
when gulps come and help us so gulp can
actually every time I added something
here and I saved the file
gulp can do all that for me
automatically you can pause the file it
saved the file in a folder it get the
file from that folder and save it on
another folder and and and convert the
file whatever you want go up can do it
let's go and install gulp and for that
you're gonna need node J yes every link
that I'm gonna show here every website
that I'm going to show you I'm gonna
paste it on the description of this
video go there download it install it in
your computer it's just like a normal
app so in solid there and then after its
installed then we go here to go
jegs.com and we can install go p-- we're
gonna use our command command line
interface which a ton of people is
scared of this interface right now to
install gulp we just need to follow
these simple instructions here we can
just copy and paste it alright
remember you need to install node.js
before if not this is not gonna work
alright so let's open the command line
for now you can be on any folder but
then we need to go to our project folder
ok so first you need to install the gulp
C
because we're gonna use some specific
commands for gulp so you just need to
copy this and paste it here and hit
enter and it will install everything you
need to use the gulp command-line and
everything if you're using Mac and you
get like permission errors all you need
to do is like use um sudo sudo and then
paste that and hit enter okay I'm not
gonna do it because I already did it and
I'm just gonna load and I already have
old everything I need
alright so next thing I'm gonna do now
I'm gonna go to the folder so let's look
at my project folder is this one right
here so I'm gonna I'm just gonna write
CD space and I just gonna drag and drop
the folder I'm gonna hit enter and right
now I'm inside my project folder alright
you can double check by writing LS hit
enter it will show you the files inside
that folder and that's correct you can
just you can use PWD and it will show
you the path to that folder and this is
correct so we're good to go I'm gonna
put clear so we can clear that out we
are in our folder good and now we can
just run this command call NPM in it and
this will create like a file with a
bunch of things that it's gonna describe
our project so for example or a package
name you can put whatever you want I'm
just gonna hit enter the version I'm
just gonna hit enter again description
whatever you want I don't want to put
anything for now entry points so I'm
just hitting enter enter enter until the
end they will show you like a preview so
right now everything is empty here it
doesn't matter for now is gonna work but
I think you want to add a little bit of
description and your name and all that
stuff so I'm good yeah
all right so if we go inside a folder
now we have this new file so I'm gonna
open my editor you will see it here and
that's what we did right now that's you
know like the name the version
description all right next we're gonna
copy this this is what is going to
install gulp in our project so let's go
there let's clear this out let's paste
it let's hit enter this is gonna take a
minute or two the manager computer
alright and that's done um it's gonna
give you some warnings because of it's
gonna they're gonna tell you to update
this package or or do whatever don't
worry that's not gonna be an issue so
you will see that we have go p-- and
they're gonna tell you know the version
all the packages they added and all that
stuff so right now we have gulp inside
our folder here and now you will notice
something different in your file your
package JSON file that you create
earlier and you'll see def dependencies
gulp and diversion so for now we're just
gonna close that so don't worry about
that file just go back to the go p--
website and now we're gonna do this one
just copy just go back there let's clear
these out you know we're gonna paste
that so touch it's just a command that
will create a file so it's gonna create
a called file yeah yes and it's gonna be
empty it's just creating that file we're
gonna hit enter and that's it let's see
and now we have this gob file yeah yes
file and it's totally empty okay let's
go back and this go help you don't have
to is just this is just more for
instruction and explaining you different
commands that you can use to help if
you're confused or whatever but that's
it so we are ready
to start our project so we are here open
your gulp file is this is a very
important file this is the file that
we're gonna use and add some code here
okay the first one we're gonna create a
variable of gulp equals require and go
whoops that's the first one and you need
it it's very important you needed to run
gulp of course we're getting gulp and
now what we gonna do is adding different
packages so the first one I need is the
sass one which is going to get all my
sass files and put it in a different
folder compile everything and put a CSS
file on it alright
so I have here the packet somewhere here
I think this one here you go so in here
you can search for a ton of packages
comps that you can install using them PM
ton of packages thousands of packages
that you different you can use you can
get very very creative so this is the
one that actually get my sass file and
compiled to CSS so here it's very simple
they give you this so you can install so
let's just copy let's go there paste it
let's hit enter alright so now we have
the gulp sass already installed so we
can use it so let's go back there to our
editor alright so now we need to add
here so you can see they give you like
an example of how you can add your own
who you can use that package so let's
just copy and paste it first we need to
add the package in who require the
package so let's just copy this and
let's go back there all right cool
now this this is a task this is was
gonna run like a function that is gonna
run let's just see what's going on here
it's gonna take this sass which is this
so this one here we need to change it
because we have our sass in this sass
folder so let's go here sass and then
inside this sass folder we're gonna have
a bunch of sass files so we're gonna do
this dot sass so this is like a wild car
is gonna take every single file that we
have with this format so he's gonna take
every single one or you can you can be
very specific you can be like style dot
sass is it gonna take that but for now
I'm just gonna I want every single file
so you do that and that's done so we're
gonna happen here this is just if
there's an error they're gonna tell you
they're gonna tell you there's an error
if not it's gonna pipe and then it's
gonna run whatever you want and save
your CSS file here so all this I don't
want to confuse you all this is get is
just getting the file your sass file
compiling the file and saving the CSS
file in this folder so right now we
saved a file on a CSS folder which we
don't have is doesn't exist but gulp is
gonna create the folder for us so you
don't have to ok so let's save that and
let's test it so our task name is sass
so let's go and say cope sass hit enter
all right you can see here no errors no
nothing is just saying low you know
started the sass task it's finished
after this time we're good to go if you
go back now to your editor you will see
a new CSS folder let's open that folder
there's a style dot CSS which is the
same naina this one now look at this
normal CSS very cool on gulp is helping
us to do that for us
now I need to create another task for
the CSS because I want to then get all
the CSS and minify the CSS so let's go
back there we need the ugly face CSS
package so it's same thing they have
here the install command line so let's
copy this clear all this all right so
let's paste it and hit enter all right
cool same thing now we have the ugly fly
CSS installed and ready to use so let's
go here and now we can actually use it
it's copy let's paste it here alright so
as you can see is kind of doing the same
thing all over again when you have a new
package I'm just gonna put this one down
here just because I want it you don't
have to do it like that but alright so
right now is the task is called CSS and
it's gonna take the file from there so
let's change it use it gonna be inside
our CSS folder and I'm gonna do the same
thing every file with a CSS format it's
gonna is gonna take it and uglify it
which is another word for minified
and we have some options here that I'm
gonna explain to you what they do so for
example max line length is like every 80
characters I want a new line which I
don't want to but I'm gonna leave it
like that so we can see how it looks and
he's gonna save it on a folder named
dist I'm gonna live it like that this
can be whatever you want really I'm
gonna live it like that I'm gonna save
this and let's run this task let's do it
let's do gulp CSS hit enter all right
cool everything it seems to work and now
you'll notice that we have a new dist
folder let's open that we have a style
dot CSS here and there you can now even
now we can see that is and minified CSS
file this is a good file that we can use
on our production like this is what you
are gonna you're gonna upload to your
server it's gonna be very fast but this
is what I don't like about the max
length option thing is creating new
lines for us so I'm just gonna remove
that save it again I'm gonna run a go
p-- CSS let's see if it change
this is what I'm looking for so now we
have only one line of code with all the
CSS in that line of code and this is
perfect this is what I like and now this
is what I'm using on my website as you
can see is getting from the dist folder
style.css and that's what I'm using so
let's see if this is working right now
all right
so it's reading the CSS just fine
everything looks looks great so let's
close this and this we don't need it now
alright but the thing is that now you
need to go there and kind of use gold
sass or gold CSS every time you want to
do it and that's not what I want right
do you want everything to be
automatically my goal is every time I
change something in my sass file and hit
save everything will change
automatically I don't have to go here
and type the task so let's go to gulp
file Jas and let's add some stuff so I'm
going to get a new task go up dub task
and this is gonna be called whatever I
want but I'm gonna call it run and it's
gonna run my sass task and my CSS desk
right that's cool but now I want to go a
little bit further so I'm gonna write
another task and this one's gonna be
called watch and we're gonna run a
function for this one
all right and this is the one that I
like this is the one that is gonna do
everything for you automatically without
touching the command line okay so we're
gonna do two gold watch and the files
that we want to watch everything
everything every time I changed my sass
file so let's go and sass if I change
any file with the sass it's gonna run my
sass sorry like this okay same thing to
CSS so if my CSS changes I want to go so
let's go to the folder oops
CSS same thing every single CSS that I
have there is gonna run my CSS desc
alright so that's what
now I'm gonna create a task there's
gonna be the default task so let's go
there fault
now I'm gonna do I'm gonna run my run
task and my wash task so when I say
default is gulp so if I if I write gulp
he's gonna give you an error right now
because we don't have it yet but we
created so let's save this file and now
let's see if it works so let's go go
oops sorry sorry sorry sorry
you need a coma after the tasks named
coma save it again let's clear this gulp
and there you go so everything runs and
now it's kind of a washing our file so
gulp is kind of um watching you and if
you make a change it will go again and
run everything again right if you want
to get out of here of this watching
state you just need to hit ctrl C and
you will see that we go like back to
normal
alright but that's not our water what I
want so gulp alright cool so let's go to
this sass alright make sure you're
watching this because I want to know if
you change so make sure you're watching
this let's go to this sass file let's
change I don't know the font size for
example let's save it
alright this reload the page and it's
changing so every time I save my sass
file is compiling my file he's doing all
this it's compiling my file to CSS is
getting my CSS and minifying my CSS
and then it's washing our files every
time we do this so it's kind of an
automated workflow and this is only the
basics okay this is very simple right
now this can be very very complicated
you can save your file and you can do a
ton of things you can do everything with
JavaScript for example this is only CSS
we can we can run prefixes we can do
JavaScript minify - we can do babel so
you can you can do a ton of things with
gulp this is only the basics with with a
sass file compile and stuff like that so
I hope you like this and that's it